[Music]  this chaos in here  the fun of moon night is getting  introduced  it's a real legend i can't tell the  difference  between my weighty lives  and dreams  her character has got an incredibly  unique visual look  our job was to kind of put a lens on the  thing juice and ultimately take the  mental health aspect  i am  stephen  the way we're tackling the story we  learn about stephen what's wrong with  you mark  why did you call me mark  [Music]  the tone is indiana jones it's a bit  dark at times  so vast and supernatural it's amazing  thank you  every aspect of this show  and we've shifted the paradigm  for me what's really exciting is that  it's  [Music]  you